good morning believe nation if you want
to do something great great with your
business great with your life I'm going
to share with you an inspiring clip from
Will Smith that I think you'll enjoy
greatness is not this wonderful esoteric
illusive godlike feature that only the
special among us will ever taste you
know it's something that truly exists in
all of us it's very simple this is what
I believe and I'm willing to die for it
yeah period it's that simple I Know Who
I am and I know what I believe I know
who I am I know who what that's all I
need to know that's how hard you know so
from there you do what you need to do
you know and I think what happens is we
make this situation more complex than it
has been looking for complexities got to
be something complex to understand it
can't be that easy no we didn't grow up
with the sense that where we were was
where we were going to be you know we
grew up with the sense that where we
were almost didn't matter because we
were becoming we were becoming right
something greater so first stop Will
Smith is a powerhouse he's a motivator
I hope honestly one day that he runs for
public office because I think he could
do a lot of great for his country what
really struck me from that quote was
really that last part where he's talking
about where he grew up in his mind
didn't have to be where he ended up he
aspired for greatness he's fight for
something way more than where he was at
right now and that's a problem for a lot
of entrepreneurs because you spend so
much time looking at what you have right
now you look at the money that's in your
bank account right now you look at the
education that you might have right now
you look at the opportunities that are
in front of you right now you look at
the people who are in your network and
your circle of friends right now and you
think you look at all this you look at
your bank account and say well this is
where I am
now how am I ever gonna go out and do
something great in my life how is that
ever gonna happen when you look at what
you're doing right now and as long as
you hold that mindset as long as you
keep that environment then you're never
gonna achieve anything great you're
always gonna be locked down the
difference comes when you start to
change your environment if you want to
do something great if you want to be
great then you need to be surrounded by
greatness and that starts right now
what's in your office what's in your
house who are the people you hang out
with what are the videos you watch what
are the books you read surround yourself
with greatness daily you have to make it
a regular practice it can't just be
something that you do once a week or
once a month because you get that little
spike the little moment of boldness a
little spark of inspiration you go off
and you're thinking you do something and
then you get smack back down the reality
because your environment doesn't support
you so where you are now has nothing to
do with where you can go the difference
comes when you change your mindset and
you change your environment believe
thank you guys so much for watching my
question of the day for you today is
what do you do to surround yourself with
greatness what do you do in your
environment in your habits in your
routine to to push you out of your
comfort zone I want you to share it in
the comments below I think people could
really learn from what you've done and
I'm excited to join in the conversation
as well and of course if you like this
video and you want to see more don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
the newsletter thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning to help kick start your day with
a little more entrepreneurial greatness
and inspiration